.
Plusieurs sortaient pour se
mett  à l'abri du côté
ukrainien. Demande se sent un
peu prisonnier de ce conflit qui
s'isisisisisisisisisisisisisisià
le reportage que nous vous avons
prararé.
àààààààààààààààààààààààààààààààt
faire les derniers 800 m
qui s s séparent de l'Ukraine,
celle toujours sous le contrôle
du gouvernement. Ils habitent
des villes de la république
autoproclamée de Lougansk.Ils sr
y rester, quelques heures avant
que la Russie ne reconnaisse
et ordonne le déploiement
de troupes.
"Nous sommes des patriotes,
alors nous venons en Ukraine",
dit Dina.ininininininininininine
pour son frère, resté derrière.
Il sera forcé à se battre pour
les rebelles indépendantistes,
elle en est convaivovovovovovov.
Il ne l'a pas reçue encore,
mais, de toute façon,
ils les prennent dans la rue,
dit-elle, ToToToToToToToToToToT"
Ils peuvent encore quitter
sans problème, nous disent-ils,
mais pas question pour ce couple
dans les convois d'évacuation.
"Ils fabriquent une ambiance
de peur pour forcer les gens
dit Guennadi, mais c'est pour
les images, pour faire un film e
à l'abri d'une possible
intensification des combats,
tout en sachant très bien
qu
de passage, la situation
sécuritaire n'est guère mieux. r
quand les vitres de sa maison
ont été soufflées par
un mortier, le toit, endommagé.
Il est tombé dans so, , , , , ,t
chez sa mère, juste à côté.
mais c'est une honte, une honte,
dit-elle. Quand ça v
Ça fait déjà tant d'années!
Depuis 2014. Nous sommes
de temps à nous user les nerfs
avec ces tc c c c c cette
guerre? demande-t-elle.
Nous sommes prisonniers
de cette situation."
Ses voisins sont tous venus
lui prêter main-forte
pour nsosososososososososososose
par les bourrasques de vent.
(jappement)
Encore beaucoup d'Ukrainiens
de mètres des positions
de l'armée ukrainienne,
de plus en plus pris pour cible.
L'Ukraine n'a pas ordonné
C'est le cas ici, tout près
de ce poste d'obse
de l'armée.
"Ils restent ici de plein gré,
nous dit ce commandant,
c'est notre devoir."
grgrgrgrgrgré pour certains,
peut-être, mais il y a une sorte
de fatalité imposée dans la vie
qui longent la ligne de front.
(détonation au loin)
réveillée au son d'une pluie
de tirs de mortier et
d'artillerie dès 6 h ce matin.
En fin de journée,sisisisisisise
d'accalmie. Le bruit sourd
des détonations était constant.
(détonations au loin)
Trois obus sont tombés
devant la station-service
où travaille Ruslan,
mais ididididididididididididid,
on ne peut pas laisser
la station. Peut-être que
notre patron nous dira
autrement, mais  e e e e e e e "
Voilà ce que l'on sent,
des bruits de la guerre :
lalalalalalalassitude,
l'impuissance.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédar